hey what's up my name is samuel leeds i
just arrived in wales
the weather is a little bit grim here
one of my students lives in this street
now when i first met her
she didn't have any money at all she was
working actually as a solicitor so she
was making decent money but she had no
savings
she became a student of mine she learned
about how to buy properties
without using any of your own money
she's implemented that
now she's completely financially free
making hundreds of thousands of pounds
and on top of that she's buying houses
using none of her own money all over the
place so i'll introduce to her
she can share what's what hannah mills
what's happening hello how are you doing
good to see ya
so this is where you live it is yeah but
you've got houses all over the place
tell me where do you own the houses
uh so this is obviously my first one
that we bought yeah that we live in
um we own uh the one with the uh the
gray
inner we're buying the one that's next
to it yeah
and we also own the one that's just over
there so you're like you own that house
that house that house andy's house
that's incredible awesome so i want to
know
how are you buying these using none of
your own money
what's the structure why don't you show
us around the house and tell us how you
secured them and how you did the
finances yeah 100
so um basically uh all with investors
money yeah
um so we've got a slightly different
arrangement on a couple of the houses
um so this particular one we bought with
investors money completely outright
so we haven't put any money in there
they funded everything cash okay
and the deal is we sort out everything
so they got this below market value
yeah we sort out the refurb um we manage
everything and then we sweat out sale
and then at the end of it basically and
once they've got all their initial
investment back we just split the profit
50 50. okay so basically they put all
the money in yep
but you found it yep you push the value
up yep which they pay for yeah then you
refinance it yep
use that remortgage to pay them back and
then you own the house 50 50. 100
but because you keep doing it yeah it
works really well all right cool so tell
me about this house show you around so
this one basically
um it was a two bed um but it's now a
full bed so what we did is we made the
living room bigger
as you can see there used to be a
corridor here a carp corridor
boxed in the stairs um so it's just one
big living space now because
for a family it's nice to have a bigger
living space yeah so
coming to the kitchen so again we've
opened this out it was like uh
closed off this will be the kitchen here
you can see literally the markings where
the cabinets are going to be on the wall
yeah um and this is really run down
yeah it was bad so the property hadn't
been it wasn't bad it is bad
yeah why is it the moment is it worse uh
yeah so how much is this how much is
this going to cost to refurb this whole
thing about it's probably going to come
in around 31.
31 000 pounds yeah it's a small house
yeah and you how much
did you buy it for 69. 69. so all in all
you're talking 100
yeah yeah roughly and then you've got
your fees and stuff yeah what's the new
value gonna be
uh well uh re-value in terms of mortgage
because that's obviously different you
know to flip value it's probably gonna
be anywhere between 114
to 142 because it's four beds
pounds of yeah and what are you gonna do
or sell it
i think we might flip this one okay um
if we flip it it's probably gonna go for
anywhere around 150 to one
five two percent very nice yeah so how
did you buy it so cheap how did you buy
it for 69
and then resell it for 150. um so
um essentially it's my neighbor's
property
and sadly i found out that the lady who
lived in this
property passed away and i put a letter
for the door
um and the family that were clearing out
the house
saw my letter rung me up and said um
how's carrying it out do you want to
come and have a look
and i said yeah great um had a little
look around did a video
priced up the refurb i'm literally
within an hour
i went back to him and said i'll office
uh i'll offer you 62.
so he came back and he said um oh no we
want
we want 69. um so i just said yes
so they just wanted a quick sale cash
happy
but here's where the best thing comes so
mint house looking around
he goes oh um the house next door um is
my mother's house we're also thinking
about selling that one as well don't
have a look
i was like yeah of course i do 100
so i actually ended up getting two
houses for one um because i didn't
realize i was gonna get the other one so
the other one we're buying at the moment
again for 69.
so you're now working full time as a
property investor yep are you making
more money now or making more money you
were when you're a solicitor
no making i'm making more money now a
lot more uh yeah
in that case show me upstairs right
so uh like i said we turn it in from two
bedrooms to four
okay that's how you add in the value so
you're buying it as a two bed
and then you're turning it into a four
bed all right
so tell me how you did that give me the
jiggery poker
yeah so basically uh long story short
this used to be a bathroom
this space here was just a root like a
random cupboard yeah so we squared it
off made it a rectangular room
shoved the family bathroom in there
because downstairs we've also got down
to this toilet as well so
family bathroom first singles in here
it's not actually a bad routine it's a
proper single moment yeah it's not too
bad
size wise we've managed to do all right
basically what we did is we nicked a
couple of feet in
in the family bathroom first single here
so this is where the first bedroom the
new one was created
um and if we walk out now um
this double was already here which
you'll see in here nice size double
um it's not too bad um yeah
nothing's really changed new door new
radiator
obviously skim the walls and stuff right
but this is where the volume was created
so this hole this whole room here
was one big room so we basically put
a uh sub hole in the middle yeah
um and uh sectioned off the rooms we've
got nice-sized double here and then
we've got the other single in there
right so this one was just one big room
here
yeah and then one room down there you
split this into two rooms yeah you've
changed the bathroom around
that and how did you figure that out
looking at the floor plan
to be honest with you um there was no
floor plan there was no floor plan but
you
the thing is with the valleys because
i've obviously looked at a lot of houses
and i know
how they're set up you'll find that this
bedroom here a lot of people
um will have one big bedroom and they
have two windows
as well just knew by looking at it yeah
what other people have done in the area
yeah
yeah so i'll show you in here this is
kind of cool it's quirky this is
so this is a feature of a bunny's house
yeah that actually goes who's next door
oh nice okay um you don't own that yet
though
no not yet oh yeah yeah not yet so this
is this is our
final single basically and the cool
thing is like i said because it goes
through next door
actually got covered supposed there yeah
um which is cool painting nice
yeah so windows yeah so the windows
aren't actually that old they're
probably about i think they got replaced
maybe about five
seven years ago but they're obviously
brown they're horrible so what we're
doing at the moment is um we've bought
this really
expensive upvc paint that binds the
plastic
these will all be great nice yeah clean
the windows
paint it great match it with the outside
bit
yeah so what's the difference between
this house yeah you bought for 69
and turned it from a two bedroom four
bed to some of the other houses that you
own on the street and that you buy
do i take this in another house so i'll
take you to a house i've bought with um
jacob armstrong
one of myself with james okay cool
another academy member
boom yeah so um
about doing something in south wales and
it just kind of transpired that we went
to this one
and james james by the way anyone
doesn't know james i met him when he was
19.
he was working as an electrician's
apprentice he was broke he had no money
he now put the money into this house he
did yes he put all the money in
hannah found the deal they're going 50
50 on the profits hannah just keeps
buying houses like playing real life
monopoly
with none of her own money but to the
best type of game to play
it really is it is the best game so next
one
so this one this one is really old
so you can see here how much did you buy
it for 10 frames so this one was bought
for an estate agent so it was 65 this
one was okay a bit more expensive
um then obviously the one over 65 grand
on this street when they're selling for
150 when they're new
this is really old you can smell the old
masks it is
well i don't know if you can see from
the camera but can you see how the
ceiling's kind of blurred a little bit
yeah i can i've found
yeah so how much is it going to cost to
do this to refill this into our house
it's going to cost around 35.
about 35 grand so you bought it for 65.
spending 35 on it
that means 100 grand again yeah so we're
gonna flip this one um i'm hoping it's
gonna get around
considering worrying about 1 30 so nice
tidy little profit
and how many bedrooms will this be this
will be we're going to keep this one as
a three bed
nice okay are you going to knock this
through you're going to keep this
yes knocking it through yep people like
that big open front room
yeah especially at the moment this is
going to be rsj beam
straight away across yeah we should have
one big living room right show us the
kitchen
kitchen is tiny so this one is gonna
it's
gonna take a bit of configuration um
because this is actually an extension so
you've got water covered in there we're
basically just going to take that out
um unit is going to stay here back door
will stay there but it'll be a new one
but we're going to slightly basically
move the cabinets in a way here so we've
got
more space um and then the bathroom
again
is a bit of a weird one you've got
toilet just in there and then i don't
know if you want to look at this this is
your typical
old style valley bathroom oh yeah
and we've got a little bit of avocado
going on so you've got a lot of jiggery
pokers do to make this look fabulous
this is this is
this is a folger i mean literally back
to brick yeah
all right tell me upstairs yeah right
upstairs so upstairs we've got two
doubles in a single it's it's quite
quite nice in terms of uh space we've
got to play with we did toy we've put in
a bathroom
um in that space in the hallway but
we're not gonna so this is the first
double it's bat
just to give you an idea this is how run
down the house is
it's pretty bad wow so um
the reason why the walls and everything
is so bad here yeah they look black
um it's because um partly it's because
it's so old this is just the old
material
that they used to use and this is the
plaster that's blown
um single glazing punch through there oh
yeah single glazing um
and the carpets like i don't know who
picked these but look at this bad boy
that's straight back from the 60s
yeah um but there's no central heating
up here
yeah nothing i tell it's freezing uh so
the lady that lived here actually lived
here
for years and years without central
heating upstairs oh no
so three beds yeah but the thing is it's
a good sized house
it's in a good location and those are
the two things that you can't change
so you're gonna buy this well you've
already bought it you own this
you bought it with james he's also on
the academy you finished the academy
how was the academy yeah yeah it was uh
it was an experience
because you chucked me halfway in the
academy in the evictions
like i said i met a lot of people uh i
enjoyed what i learned
and and i'm here now yeah yeah and now
inspiring other people
well hopefully yeah sure i mean you
don't understand houses in this street
you've got houses all over the place
yeah yeah so we
we've got um uh in other so we're in one
particular valley at the moment in south
wales um
we've got houses dotted around other
valleys yeah incredible yeah and you've
also got rent to rent
yeah you're making thousands of pounds a
month off of those yeah yeah we're not
doing badly off those you've got a deal
packaging business
yeah that's really insane killing it
right let's go back outside
yep man there's a lot of junk look at
this
we buy houses yeah they got in too late
they're not even too late because you
bought the house yeah i know what would
you say like top
top three tips to not only buying houses
cheap but also buying houses
with none of your own money what what
are the things how do people do that
that are watching
number one top tip you've got well
you've got to find the houses first
haven't you
know how to find them yeah find the
deals get the deals
second tip from me find the investors
build trust get around good people
yeah third tip i would say probably uh
is to do like around your knowledge so
once you've found it how are you gonna
complete it that's the thing because
everyone can find it how'd you get it
over the line so here's the thing guys
ultimately it's all about what you know
i think the best investment is not
property this is a good investment
you're going to be able to push the
value up but the best investment i
believe is you know what i'm going to
say
it's the best investment what do you
reckon what do you reckon people people
invest in yourself once you've invested
in yourself that's what hannah did she
invested in herself
now she's investing in property now
she's making loads of money so
watch my youtubes get the knowledge
check more check out more videos i've
got a whole playlist i think you're
going to enjoy which you can check out
right here
also don't forget to subscribe to the
channel which you can do right here and
i look forward to seeing you next time